mein Thema heute Abend sind aber die
Klima Kleber ich nenne sie eher
klimakriminelle denn die gefährden
Menschenleben ich will das Wort
klimakriminelle hier sehr sehr bewusst
denn die klimakleber geben für mich viel
zu weit ich finde ja dass allein dieses
Wort die Aktivitäten dieser Bewegung
verniedlicht Klima Kleber erinnert mich
immer an ein Aktivität im Kindergarten
mit roten Buntstiften und grünen Bäumen
wo klimazeichnung aufgeklebt werden wir
müssen sie endlich als das bezeichnen
was sie sind Kriminelle denn wer Straßen
blockiert indem er sich an den Boden
klebt hilft nicht dem Klima sondern
gefährdet Menschenleben wie es jetzt
gerade hier in Berlin leider passiert
ist die ökoextremisten haben durch eine
klebeblockade auf der Stadtautobahn ein
Stau verursacht und so die Rettung einer
Schwerverletzten gefährdet ein dringend
benötigtes Spezialfahrzeug konnte nicht
rechtzeitig zu der Radfahrerin gelangen
jetzt kämpft die Frau um ihr Leben die
Verantwortlichen gehören für mich ins
Gefängnis und ich würde gerne die Runde
eröffnen mit Carsten Stahl ob er
zustimmt oder sagt nein die gehören
nicht ins Gefängnis
soll ich die Handschellen rausholen wir
gehen auf die Straße und wir zeigen mal
was Aktivismus bedeutet ich bin seit
neun Jahren im Kinderschutz und
Kinderschutz Aktivist ich habe noch nie
in der Zeit in irgendeine Weise
Menschenleben gefährdet mich irgendwo
angeklebt irgendwelche Straßenblock
haben gemacht
Rettungsfahrzeuge daran gehindert
Menschenleben zu schützen und zu
bewahren und wenn ich dann noch höre
dass ich jemand hinstellt einer der die
Fürsprecher ist und sagt shit happens
wir sind wir sind im klimakampf und ich
im klimakuscheln da sah ich Herr Müller
tun sie mir gefallen halten Sie die
Fresse halten Sie einfach die Fresse
wenn sie keine Ahnung haben und wenn sie
sich profilieren wollen suchen sich
einen Job machen sie was vernünftigen so
scheiße Schaufeln aber zählen sie nicht
so viel Scheiße es ist unfassbar weil
ihr den Menschen in diesem Land zumutet
mit eurer grünen Ideologie und eurem
grünen Wahnsinn unser Land hier in
Geiselhaft zu nehmen statt einer aber
jetzt Menschenleben zu gefährden oder
hier wieder bei den Dinosauriern Kindern
mit zu missbrauchen in eure Ideologie
mit einzuspannen es reicht
sonst bin ich vielleicht auch mal der
Meinung gehen wir mit unseren Aktivisten
auf die Straße und Schaufeln vielleicht
mal ein bisschen Scheiße Weg aus den ja
Gehweg Rinnen also zusammengefasst die
sollten jetzt zu und ich persönlich sage
das Problem ist ja eins die kommen ja
meistens ausreichend Haushalten
Geldstrafen werden die gar nicht
ausmachen wenn selbst aussprechen 10.000
Euro bezahlt Papi oder Mami aber wenn
man so zu drei Monaten Haft vielleicht
mal wegsperren zum latinen Putzen ja
dann ist das vielleicht unangenehm wie
haben Sie denn schon gejammert als VW
oder Porsche das Licht ausgemacht hat
und denn die Heizung ausgeschaltet hat
und dann durfte nicht auf toilettchen oh
unsere luxusklimaaktivisten fandet nicht
schick aber solange unser Politik auf
dem linken und dem grünen Auge blind ist
und sie verharmlosen so wie du das
gesagt hast werden sie weitermachen sich
animiertüren und sie werden sich
formieren immer weitermachen ich sage es
reicht das sind Kriminelle wir Menschen
Leben gefährdet gehört ins Gefängnis
Carsten Stahl hat ja Herrn Müller wehnt
ich weiß nicht ob jeder das weiß also
dieser Tweet von dem du gesprochen hast
Carsten der kommt ja von Tacho Müller
das ist so seit 20 Jahren er selber
bezeichnet sich so als Vorreiter dieser
ganzen Aktivisten Szene muss jetzt so
ein bisschen ist auch in die Jahre
gekommen muss gucken wo er bleibt weil
natürlich die lebensmaß und die anderen
Luisa Neubauer kam ihm da das Wasser ab
deswegen
radikalisiert er sich immer mehr und man
kann es ja alles nachgucken im Internet
es gibt vor einem Jahr ein
entsprechendes Youtube Video aus
Frankfurt wo er da ganz genau die
Kaskade des Protestes durch exerziert
und sagt sogar dass diese Bewegung
in Kauf nimmt Polizisten zu provozieren
um über den Polizisten die Ausschreitung
der Polizisten wiederum in die Medien zu
kommen und ihre Sachen dann eben in den
Medien vorbringen zu können also das ist
eine Kaskade wir da wenn Sie sich das
Video anguckt ab ungefähr Minute 15 da
auffüllt das ist schon irre und vor
Zeit hat genau dieser gleiche Tag your
client gesprochen von der grünen RAF und
fand das irgendwie ganz witzig und da
wird es tatsächlich ein bisschen
gefährlich weil das werden auch die
Grünen die meisten zumindest nicht
wollen in dieser Ecke gesteckt zu werden
aber es ist natürlich etwas was
hochgefährlich ist weil meistens beginnt
es ja gerade wenn es um ein höheres gut
geht und den Kampf für Demokratie im
positiven den Kampf gegen vermeintliche
Mächten den Vietnamkrieg oder sonst was
da geht es mal los mit dem farbein mit
dem Farbbeutel dann beginnt mit
irgendwelchen Sachen gegen Gemälde man
klebt sich an aber der Schritt wenn man
dann von der grünen RF spricht zu
weiterer Radikalisierung ist zumindest
in der Vergangenheit für ein Teil dieser
Gruppierung immer der nächste Schritt
gewesen und da wird es dann wirklich auf
genauso wie bei solchen Tweets die wir
von ihm gesehen haben politische
Bewegung sprechen würde ich sie gerne
einmal fragen Herr Münkler wie kommt es
denn zu dieser politischen Bewegung
dieser Klimabewegung und wie weit werden
die gehen
wie weit sie gehen werden dass lässt
sich schlecht Voraussagen meine es kann
ja sein dass sie jetzt gewissermaßen das
Unheil dass sie da angerichtet haben als
eine Art Stoppschild begreifen aber das
entscheidende glaube ich liegt auf einer
anderen Ebene sie sind für sozusagen das
Spiegelbild des Populismus sie halten
sich nämlich ja letzten Endes für eine
avantgardistische Elite sie glauben sie
wissen mehr sie müssen sich nicht auf
den Prozess der Demokratie nämlich
Kompromissbildung einlassen sondern
erheben für sich einen Anspruch
eigentlich absoluten bestens nicht und
insofern kann man sagen das sind keine
Freunde der Demokratie auch in der Art
wie sie auftreten sondern sie können
eher auf Sicht gefährlich für sie werden
und von einer religiösen Bewegung so
etwas wie einer Sekte wenn man sagt dass
sie sich eigentlich gar nicht an der
demokratiebildung dann beteiligen wollen
ja ja ich meine sozusagen absolutes
Wissen ist in der Regel wissen dass man
über Propheten oder andere hat und das
auch nicht zur Disposition gestellt
werden kann und auch nicht
kompromissfähig ist in der Praxis und
von daher
kann man sagen das hebelt die Demokratie
von ihrem Grundverständnis her aus und
insofern glaube ich dass man das Problem
jetzt nicht angeht indem man sagt das
sind Kriminelle das muss der Rechtsstaat
irgendeiner Weise klären das ist nicht
unsere Sache das zu entscheiden
klimakleber nicht etwas niedlich ich
finde klimakleber dafür dass jetzt ein
Menschenleben gefährdet wurde Straßen
blockiert werden Menschen nicht und
dementsprechend auch Rettungswagen
durchkommen ihres Berufsstandes möchte
Journalisten die sozusagen so eine
Bezeichnung offenbar wegen der
Alliteration
ja straßenblockierer zunächst einmal
nicht zu einer richtigen Alliteration
wird es erst bei kritische klimakleber
sowas
aufhören
jetzt gut die kleben sich nun mal fest
womit ich immer ein Problem habe ist
dass sie immer als Aktivisten als
klimaaktivisten bezeichnet werden was
sie zwar auch sind aber es sind auch vor
allen Dingen Extremisten und das sehe
ich ein großes Problem dass unser Staat
in weiten Teilen gerade in Berlin ist es
zu spüren der Berliner Senat fast diese
sogenannten Aktivisten mit
Samthandschuhen an im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes den werden ja mit Speiseöl nahezu
zärtlich dann die die Finger vom Asphalt
geholt während dann Leute im Stau warten
die auf dem wichtigen Termin müssen oder
eventuell sogar jemandem das Leben
retten müssen Sie vorschlagen die
abgelöst werden ich habe in einem
anderen Publikation aus Ihrem Hause der
Berliner Boulevardzeitung BZ vorhin
einen Artikel gelesen der wurden dir als
Öko Extremisten bezeichnet das sind sie
es sind Linksextremisten auch weil sie
auch das öko ist für die auch nur ein
Vorwand um letztendlich die Abschaffung
des Rassismus anzustreben und mit
Demokratie haben die wirklich nichts am
Hut wenn der gleiche Protest von rechts
käme und sich zum Beispiel etwa gegen
die unkontrollierte Migration richten
würde was meinen Sie wie schnell die von
den Straßen weg wären und zu was für
Gefängnisstrafen die verdonnert werden
will das wäre ganz klar sind
Linksextremisten für sie genauso schlimm
wie Rechtsextremisten das kann man nicht
also man kann es nicht vergleichen weil
es ist einfach nicht dasselbe in
gewissen Ausprägungen natürlich ähneln
sich dann wieder nämlich dass sie
nämlich die Demokratie letztendlich
abschaffen wollen die einen wollen
vielleicht den Führerstand die anderen
die kommunistische was weiß ich finde es
Rede Republik und setzen dafür auch
Gewalt als legitimes Mittel ein und das
ist für mich der Unterschied sobald man
darf sich streiten man darf
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein man darf
auch das System überwinden oder
abschaffen wollen das muss man auch
können Demokratie aber sobald man dazu
Gewalt einsetzt und dazu zählt auch so
eine Blockade das würde ich auch als
Gewalt erzählen man sieht es in den
Auswirkungen dann muss Schluss sein und
dann muss der Rechtsstaat ganz
wirklich ganz stark dagegen vorgehen
damit Leute wie sie ich verstehe ihre
Aufregung und man sieht es ihnen auch an
dass sie durchaus in der Lage werden mit
den Leuten fertig zu werden aber genau
das darf ja nicht passieren das wäre
selbst Justiz und das wollen wir Gottes
machen
die Polizei ist ja nicht vor Ort sie ist
Polizei sind nicht vor Ort die geben
sich da fest und dann haben sie da
Menschen und nicht jeder reagiert leicht
und wenn dann ja jemand sitzt so wie
letztens der dann verbal entglitten ist
und sein Kind dann genommen ist in die
Mutter ist gefahren und er hat die jetzt
wird wortwillig uns jetzt mal einer
sparen gesagt hat der da kann und das
wird und das kann ich halt nur an so ich
komme aus einer aus einer Gewalt Zeit
ich komme aus Berlin Neukölln ich habe
viele Dinge erlebt man sieht mir das mit
Sicherheit auch an und viele wissen das
auch und ich merke ja wie diese Grenzen
immer mehr schwinden und die Leute immer
wieder gewaltbereiter sind und das jetzt
in der Zeit wo die sowieso alles nicht
Schnauze voll haben durch die Politik
und durch die ganzen Entbehrung
zweieinhalb Jahre Pandemie jetzt das es
brodelt und jetzt kriegen die sich da
auf Kniehöhe und Fußballplatz
fest verstehen sie ich sehe das schon
dass das passieren wird und dann wird
uns alles was extrem ist ob wir extrem
Gewalt extrem links extrem rechts extrem
egal wie ist immer gefährlich und das
sind so einer Zeit wenn man seine Ziele
durchsetzen möchte dann gibt es andere
Möglichkeiten ich mache seit neun Jahren
Aktivismus ich habe sowas noch nicht
gebracht und bei mir geht es um Kinder
und dann stellen sie sich hin und sagen
das geht um die Zukunft der Kinder die
gleichen Herren und Darm habe ich noch
nie aufschreiben hören dass im Jahr
offiziell fast 20.000 Kinder missbraucht
werden da hört die nicht auf schreien
aber sie nehmen Kinder an die Hand und
missbrauchen sie benutzen sie für ihren
Idealismus der soweit geht Klima alles
wunderbar müssen wir mal tun aber nicht
auf die Art und Weise wenn wir jetzt die
These mit einem mit einer Lösung beenden
wollen Bela was würdest du denn der
Regierung raten vielleicht sogar auch in
der Kommunikation mit den
klimaextremisten ökoextremisten naja ich
meine es bringt sicherlich nichts gut
den gut zuzureden weil
wie gesagt ich nicht nur jedem raten
schaut man sich das an dieses Video von
Tacho kleinen ist klar dass das einer
Strategie folgt und die Strategie ist
eben durch solche Maßnahmen
Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren zum Teil
auch nicht bei allen sicherlich Polizei
zu provozieren um die Taten der Polizei
dann eben entsprechend aufzunehmen und
dann über den den die Erregung über
diese Missetaten der Polizei sich selbst
ins Gespräch zu bringen ist da und Klein
erklärt also folgt es einer Methode
nicht bei allen es gibt auch das müssen
wir auch sagen fast bei denen die dabei
sind auch ein paar die denken wirklich
morgen geht die Welt unter wenn ich mich
jetzt hier nicht festklebe das gibt es
auch aber ich würde sagen du hast
gefragt nicht den Methoden ich würde
hier hart durchgreifen bei jede
klebeaktion mehr erhöht die
Akzeptanz von diesen Aktionen die wird
und motiviert natürlich weiteres zu tun
wir werden weiter solche Dinge sehen wie
wir gesehen haben dass Rettungswagen
nicht durchkommen und dergleichen da
wird jemand hinfahren ist es nicht gut
wenn wir einfach sagen okay berechtigt
ist ansehen kleben wir euch mal da
wieder ab